y
[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de los
observadores de france 24 el programa de
hecho 100% con las imágenes de nuestros
aficionados iniciaremos en hong kong
donde la pastelería se ha vuelto
importante para enviar mensajes
políticos luego iremos a venezuela donde
una marea negra afecta el ecosistema y
para finalizar hablaremos de la triste
historia de un elefante en cosa de
martín
los pasteles de luna estos pasteles
tradicionales chinos son muy populares
durante la fiesta de medio otoño en
china el año pasado unos pasteleros en
hong kong utilizaron estas tortas para
apoyar el movimiento prodemocracia en
este se podía leer sin retirada sin
dispersión pero este año ya no se leen
mensajes en las tortas porque está
prohibido una ley votada en junio por el
gobierno de hong kong tiene previstas
penas de cadena perpetua por todo
mensaje de secesión o considerado
demasiado su percibo por ejemplo esta
pastelería que había escrito slogans
explícitos del año pasado ahora puso
mensajes sin hacer ninguna referencia a
las manifestaciones de este año estos
mensajes de apoyo a hong kong es lo que
se conoce como el círculo económico
amarillo unos comerciantes se apoyan el
movimiento prodemocracia y a cambio los
manifestantes prodemocracia apoyan a
estos comerciantes
incluso aunque esos mensajes empiecen a
escasear a causa de la nueva ley nuestra
observadora explica por qué a su poder
adquisitivo sigue siendo un arma
económica es difícil para los
comerciantes de expresar su punto de
vista pero el riesgo es mínimo para los
consumidores
yo quiero apoyar a los comerciantes con
los que estoy de acuerdo este movimiento
es un movimiento humanista y de libertad
para vivir sin temor nos nosotros
tenemos redes sociales páginas webs o
aplicaciones para identificar a los
comerciantes locales que comparten estos
valores para distinguir a los
comerciantes los manifestantes utilizan
el amarillo para designar a aquellos que
los apoyan y el azul para los que apoyan
a la policía de hong kong los taxistas
también se vuelven políticos algunos le
reparten calcomanías a sus pasajeros y
después los pasajeros comparten en
internet cuáles son las empresas que
apoyan su movimiento
una marea negra de gran amplitud llegó
hasta las costas del noreste de
venezuela desde finales de julio el
combustible se derramó en una refinería
local y afectó particularmente zonas
protegidas y la bióloga bilis a morón
explica algunas de las consecuencias de
esta catástrofe para el medio ambiente
en el caso de los manglares cuando el
muro se pega
raíces esto puede morir por su vocación
a la recuperación del manglares puede
llevar de 3
decorar el derrame coincidió con la
época reproductiva de bailes peces de
coral por lo que es necesaria una
evaluación en el tiempo
asimismo organismos como peces y
bivalvos se necesita una evaluación para
saber si tienen concentraciones de estos
compuestos que pueden intoxicar a los
consumidores locales y visitantes esta
marea negra no es un accidente aislado
porque al menos un 70 por ciento del
litoral venezolano ha sido afectado por
fugas de hidrocarburos según una
fundación local
además averías eléctricas incendios o
incluso explosiones ocurren de manera
regular en el seno de las instalaciones
petroleras
iván freites sindicalista del sector
petrolero da algunas explicaciones
berlín aplicado las normas cultivo
mantenimiento correspondiente empezó con
el despido de más de 20.000 compañeros
en el radio 2002 es todo esto como
consecuencia la desprofesionalización de
la industria petrolera y el
desmantelamiento de beneficios laborales
hoy en día contra los petroleros lo que
está ganando son 2 dólares al mes
esa situación ha hecho que la migración
en la industria petrolera ha llegado a
niveles muy amantes apenas están las
áreas petroleras del país entre 1000 y
1500 trabajadores esto ha traído como
consecuencia que no hay inversión
si esa meta
siempre nos encontramos siempre
el elefante que acaban de ver ha dado
mucho de qué hablar durante los últimos
años en costa de márfil este emblema
nacional protegido vivía solo y se
acostumbró a la presencia de los humanos
nuestro observador solo encontraba con
frecuencia en camino al trabajo
escuchamos que había un elefante en un
parque a unos 50 o 60 kilómetros de
white y con los años se fue acercando
hasta llegar aquí a la ciudad nunca
habíamos visto a un elefante en la
naturaleza en plena naturaleza
yo personalmente la única vez que un
elefante fue en un zoológico nos dijeron
que tenía un nombre así supimos que se
llama med aquí está la fábrica artesanal
de licor que llamamos cocktail code con
él encuentran los barriles o se agarra
toma y bueno se emborracha se acuesta y
los niños van a jugar con el uso
aunque no agrede a las personas causada
de todas maneras muchos estragos sobre
todo entre las motos rompía muchas motos
se volvió muy peligroso en un momento
dado arremetía contra los carros estudie
algunos campos el 10 de septiembre un
equipo de expertos internacionales y
representantes del ministerio de las
aguas y el bosque capturaron al elefante
para transferirlo al zoológico de abiyán
y luego se integró a la reserva en sí
donde los turistas pudieron verlo
durante su safari si un animal es
extraordinario sobre todo un paquidermo
es bonito de ver
es interesante yo era ha sido víctima de
ese elefante si no era dañado mi moto o
causado estragos
tal vez sentiría algo distinto pero en
este momento puedo decir que me duele un
poco lamentó su partida
[Aplausos]
gracias a todos nuestros observadores
por sus historias si quieren compartir
sus imágenes no duden en escribirnos a
los contactos que aparecen en pantalla
hasta pronto